let's say i run some type of sheep farm
maybe some type of wool producing
business and in year one i go out there
i buy a bunch of sheep and i put them on
some land and i go and i buy the sheep
for one million dollars and i buy the
land for 1.2 million so i have 2.2
million dollars in assets nothing
confusing there now let's go to year two
and think about how we want to account
for the sheep and the land so one way we
could say is a look the sheep are still
there the land is still there i paid a
million dollars for the sheep and
they're all still there so i'll put on
my books that the sheep are still one
million dollars and i paid 1.2 million
dollars for the land so i'll put on my
books that the land is
1.2 million dollars so in this
situation i've accounted for the sheep
and the land based on their historical
cost so let me write this down this is
based on historical cost
historical
cost
now another and this is a legitimate way
to account for things especially if
there's no other way to really think
about what my sheep or my land are worth
i had to say look this is what i paid
for them now let's say that there is an
active market in sheep and you can get a
sheep appraiser to come over to your
farm and tell you what your sheep are
worth and your sheep appraiser comes and
says wow your sheep are looking good
there's been a big i don't know sheep
epidemic in another part of the country
so there's a sheep shortage so your
sheep are actually worth a lot more than
they were last year and they say i think
your sheep are now worth two million
dollars so you say hey wow the market
value of my sheep is two million so you
could say well instead of putting one
million there let me put two million
dollars
let me put two million dollars for my
sheep and let's say that the land has
also appreciated that you know the
highways gone by and someone wants to
put a build a development nearby
so there's the fair value of your land
has also gone up maybe it's also two
million dollars so both of these so this
is two million and this is two million
so this right over here you could view
this the market value or the fair value
the fair value
of your sheep now either one of these
are legitimate ways of accounting but
it's good to know the difference this is
historical cost accounting this is fair
value accounting in general most
accounting standards boards want people
to report the fair value or the mark to
market value as as frequently as
possible it's very easy to do if there
is kind of a market in that or you can
get an appraiser and they can give you a
pretty good estimate of what these
things are worth if that isn't around or
if it's just inefficient to do it then
you'd probably want to do the historical
cost method so that's all the difference
historical cost how much you paid for it
fair value what's the current market
value today so it sounds like very fancy
words but it's a pretty simple idea